started uh with the presentation and at
any time if you have any questions
uh please do feel free uh free to
interrupt
i'll put it in the chat uh i'm sure
mohit and sonalika are watching
and they can interrupt me or i'm not
sure if they have the ability to unmute
and ask the question but
let's have a productive session here
and let me get started
hope you all can see my slides correct
[Music]
okay you all can see my splines correct
yes can everyone see my slides uh yes
ma'am we can see our slime okay thank
you
so um the plan for this
week um i'm just going to give you the
plan for this week so today we are going
to go in
steps right so today we're going to
introduce what bioinformatics is
uh overview of bioinformatics why
are we in drowned in data so the meaning
of what
big data is and then tomorrow we're
going to talk
to you about protein structure and
function
so at the end of the day in your body
there are lots of proteins
dna rna small molecules and everything
else floating around
in every single cell and all of them are
not floating around
with a which is a sequence right long
sequences
and you know your genome is six feet
long it's not like the whole
in the cell it's like you know whole
sequences
they all fold into compact
three-dimensional
structures and that is what helps them
with their functions so they have to
fold into three-dimensional structures
in order to be able to
uh do their functions within the cells
so tomorrow we're going to look at
biology in three dimensions we're going
to look at how protein structures help
us
understand functions and then we're
going to follow with
hands-on sessions where you will learn
different informatica resources that you
can go to
to get information uh uniprot which is
one of the universal resources
and protein hubs for bioinformatics in
the world
so uniprot ncbi is another
standing uh universal hub for
bioinformatics in the world
and then we'll go through ensembl and
genome-wide association studies so these
are some of the databases that we will
visit
but this should be more than enough for
you to
get a grasp and do lots of different
projects
because these are all gold mines this is
where all the data is residing
you just have to learn how to get data
from there
and use it for meaningful research
purposes so by end of this course you
will actually be
able to do that ask questions biological
questions
look at diseases that you're interested
in and you use all of these resources
and come up with a very nice project
and then we will look at structures in
three dimensions we look at the whole
biology in three dimensions
so we'll use couple of tools that
sunalika and mohit will
let you know how to download and use
and make some pretty pictures of protein
structures
understand how a single mutation in a
protein
leads to a disease so it is it is hard
to believe right there are proteins that
are
10 000 amino acids but just one single
mutation
one single change in an amino acid
changes them to an extent that they
cause disease
right and then finally we will have
applications
of bioinformatics and we'll wrap up this
week
with some activities for you to do so
that whatever you learnt
during the course of this week you will
apply to a project and you will be able
to do your own projects
so that is what this week is going to
look like and then when we get started
with the next
week uh then we'll tell you what um you
will uh get into
the speaker on friday is actually
leads one of the leaders in uniprot
which is a universal protein database so
you're gonna
hear from the horse's mouth she is the
one who leads a lot of efforts
in the databases that we'll actually be
using
so you will actually hear from the
horse's mouth
as well on on friday so so now
let's get started are you all excited so
today
the learning objectives is you will
learn the definition
if nothing else you're going to learn
what is bioinformatics right
and then what are lots of challenges
that we are facing today
because of all the data that we have and
then omics
what are the different omics right if i
go we have like 60 participants on this
call so if i ask each and every one of
you
to give me a omics term we are going to
have leftover ohmic terms so we have
like more than 300 ohmic terms right so
and that's what is leading to big data
and and this data is being used in
medicine
right to solve diseases at the end of
the day all of us are interested in
understanding diseases all of us are
interested in understanding how to solve
and cure diseases and everything else
right now we are in the pandemic and
thankfully
of course we are still in the middle of
the pandemic and we still have a long
way to go before
uh we actually get out of this pandemic
and all of you are learning about this
delta variant and i'm sure those of you
in india are
hit very hard by it and every day
my praise goes out to the whole world
and we all want to get out so
there's only one variant right there are
a couple of variants but
yet that one single variant is causing
a lot of changes in the spike protein to
increase the infectibility of this
particular virus right
why is one single variant one single
mutation
is causing so much of habit right so
those are the things that we're going to
learn
that how this is affecting of course our
topic for this week is not going to be
coveted
but i'm sure that you've learned about
covid from other courses
as well now all of this data has given
rise to a new field called the genomics
right so we are all drowning and why is
it so
important for all of us to learn this
i call this a new language in a new way
and all of us need to learn this
language
whether you want to become a scientist
you want you're already scientists
whether you're doing bioinformatics or
you want to go into machine learning you
want to go into different aspects
this is a language that you all and all
of us have to learn in order to be able
to do several aspects within the field
of bioinformatics
right and so now before we get into
bioinformatics
i want to know do you all know what this
informatics
leave alone bio will add bio to this but
what is informatics
we are all drowning in an era of
informatics so what is informatics do
you all you cannot put it in the chat
of what you think is informatics to you
what is informatics
so let's have a dialogue so that it's
not boring and some of you it's late i
don't want you to sleep so
let's make it very interactive right now
so what is informatics so whatever you
feel like just put it in the chat
of what you think is informatics and
you're you're here to learn uh some of
the aspects of
it right so dealing with information i
love that because
information right informatics so
dealing with information yes i like that
definition
um handling data for information data
that's wonderful i think all of you are
trying to put this together right so we
are dealing with information
through facts about something yes
and then computation is going too fast
for me so i'm not reading your names
here
but i'm just reading what you have here
informatic request management of large
exactly large amount of data to get
meaningfully absolutely general so
i think all of your processing data
computational information
fantastic this is an amazing group i'm
going to love it and my energy is going
to i
my energy goes up and up based on
interaction i get right so my voice will
start going up enough because i'm so
excited from it to all that you're
putting out there
alfred i think informatica is collection
and processing
exactly so to summarize every bit of
what all of you have said right
it is information that's what it's all
about and
how do you get meaningful how do you
extract
meaningful data used based on this data
how do you get information based on this
information how do you convert that to
knowledge
that is going to be meaningful to use
right amazing so it's all about data
data
right so it's all about data and how do
you process that atom
amazing all of you have already given
that right so it's a study of how
information is collected
it's stored and how do we manipulate
this data
and how is it classified how is it
organized how is it retrieved and how is
it
visualized all of this is what we're
going to learn this this week right
now how does it differ from information
technology
and how does it differ from computer
science right i'm sure
i'm sure all of i think some uh
think someone has your um
you're not muted your mind i guess
so information science computer science
so do you all
think that informatics is the same
thing as information technology is it
the same thing as computer science
yes or no you can just put yes or no
what do you think is it
is it the same as information technology
or is something different
informatics is something different from
computer science
what do you think yes no yes it is the
same
no it does not divya says yes
it is no so you both your answers are
correct it's probably a discipline
that's true
so yes and no right so so you will see
i'm gonna
yes it is yes and no both answers are
actually correct and you must be
thinking wow
what is what is going on so we're gonna
learn why both answers are correct
in a second right yes so can we live
without informatics today i'm pretty
sure
each and every one of you is going to
say what
is it yes or no can we live without
informatics today
you and me are communicating 10 000
miles away
and it's all because of technology right
so and we're just googling with the
phone and you can do lots of mathematics
yes absolutely that is the correct
answer so we cannot live within
informatics today whether you believe it
or not you
are all generating data every single day
and every single minute
all of you you may be wondering how but
you are
generating data so when you google
something up right so go to amazon or
something you're clicking
something in a way you're not aware but
you're actually generating data
as amazon is collecting every single
click to figure out who is buying what
that is done
right so all of us are living with data
and we cannot live without informatics
absolutely
not every day we are touched by
uninfluenced by informatics and i'm
pretty sure
your generation all of you use facebook
twitter
instagram and all these things right so
we are living in a data-centric world
and new data acquisition devices are
coming
we are all creating data like i said all
of you are creating data each one of us
is creating data
and various data going and each one of
us are creating different types of data
and people are using these different
types of data to figure out right so
even this vaccine how many people are
taking vaccine
and where does this vaccine roll out
which which states have better vaccine
rollout than
other states and all of those things
it's all about data right they're all
collecting data
now all of you said one thing very
nicely right so we are living in a data
centric world
but how are we going to the skills that
you all need
is how do we use this data get
information out of it meaningful
information out of it
and how do we convert that meaningful
information into knowledge
right okay so
go a little bit slow okay i will go a
little bit slow okay
and the other thing is we are knowing we
are not in a big rush so if i'm not able
to finish
everything that i plan for today we'll
continue tomorrow so
okay um i will go slow okay
now when i get excited harita i go very
fast so okay let me slow down here right
so up to now this what i'm trying to
tell you is informatics is extremely
important what is informatics
informatics is about data
it's different kinds of data and how do
we how do we get information out of this
data how do we convert that data to
knowledge
right so far that's as far as we have
gone right
now there is no escape for any one of us
even you know some of you i heard little
kids in the thing background so even
kids have to learn all of this right
so if you give a kid an ipad they know
how to figure this out right so we are
in an era
of data and how to use all of this
technology that is there right so data
keeps coming
people with needs and hunger for tools
and there are
systems that are created right so you
have data you have people you have
systems
and informatics right so data to
knowledge right so
now informatics now i want to put
informatics in perspective right so we
are talking about something
very specific right we are talking of
biological data
we are not talking about other kinds of
data right we are talking about
biological data
so there is bioinformatics there are
different types of informatics right so
you have bioinformatics it really deals
with molecules
like it deals with proteins it leads it
deals with rna it leads with dna
and then you have imaging informatics
that deals with tissues i'm sure that
you've all had an x-ray
at some point or you've had an
ultrasound at some point or
mri at some point so those are all about
tissues and
entire organ systems right and then we
have what's called clinical informatics
which is all about patients
it is all about informatics about
patients if someone has a disease
and something like that and then public
health health informatics
is populations it's about society you
and me
together we all form a society right so
this informatics in perspective right so
clinical informatics is all of this come
under the umbrella of health
informatics and biomedical informatics
is not the same as
health informatics this is all consumers
right so there is a product that is
there
if you want to measure your blood
pressure there is a product right so you
use a blood pressure
um device and that is all about consumer
health informatics right so then
what is bioinformatics this entire
course
is going to be focusing only on one
small aspect
of this whole ocean of informatics which
is called the bio
inframatics right so now coming to
what is bioinformatics you all gave an
amazing definition of what is
informatics
now let's define what is bioinformatics
you all define informatics what is
bioinformatics
any guesses of what is bioinformatics
any definitions come to your mind of
what is bioinformatics
delay yes absolutely absolutely
fantastic
interpretation of biological data that
is cool
that is correct in bridge between
biology and computer oh i love that
definition
that is exactly what the initial
definition was deals with tools
absolutely there are different aspects
to bioinformatics right
so you have a computer so a long time
ago right so it was like use a computer
and a mouse that was called an
information
and then it was biology yes that is the
science of collecting analyzing yes
absolutely this is a very good
definition
right so the national institute of
health year in the us they came up with
a formal definition of bioinformatics
it's research
development application of computational
tools and approaches
and it's pretty much about again as you
see it is the same thing that we talked
about it is yes it is collection
of biological data and how do you use
this for
looking at diseases and yes absolutely
benefits to humankind right
so analyzing visualization of
bioinformatics right
so now it's about biological data you
have you
actually do experiments in a computer
right
so it's not easy people think
bioinformatics is easy it's actually
more difficult than experimentation
right so you're doing a lot of
experiments within the computer
right so you have data how do you look
at the data how do you do calculations
of this data and how do you get
meaningful
things right so there are lots of
different sub disciplines within
bioinformatics right so
you need uh to develop algorithms right
google
right you all do all of us are so used
to doing google search right
anything you want to know you go to
google right you don't need anything
else that's scary right you don't need
me you just go to google
you just go to google you type something
and google is going to pull up something
now behind that some programmer has
developed that algorithm
and a search engine for you to do it
that programmer probably does not may
not be a biologist may not understand
proteins
right so and also the minute you have
data we need
statistics as well right so you can just
say this person has a mutation
but then now you want to see whether
it's statistically significant to see
that mutation in a population right so
it is statistics right so then you also
want to analyze this data
you want to interpret this data various
kinds of
data right nucleotide data amino acid
diet this is all biological that right
at the end of the day
and then of course you want to people to
develop tools so that
you and me there's lots of data but if
if it's not put in the form of a
database
and if it doesn't have a search engine
all of us not programmers so we won't
know how to get the data right so
so as immediately just from the slide
you can already see
that bioinformatics is an
interdisciplinary
field it needs collaboration with
different people
right different disciplines you need a
biologist to understand biology
you need mathematicians to and
statisticians to come up with algorithms
and then you need people to develop
tools right unit software engineers so
already
you know that bioinformatics is actually
an interdisciplinary field
right right and so this is about the
interpret analysis and interpretation
but today and for the next
week or two right two weeks in this
course we are only going to
focus on the biology
of all of these things right so we are
not going to do anything like
it's bioinformatics and you feel
what do you think is by
it's no absolutely okay so how many of
you
think that bioinformatics is not in your
field how old is bioinformatics
yes you're all correct that
bioinformatics
is actually not a nuclear
it is actually an old field that has
existed for a while we just didn't
name it a 1953 so i am i
i think where i i know where ahmad is
heading right but
we'll we'll talk about it yeah you no
idea okay
so bioinformatics the answer is it's
actually
not a new field it has actually existed
for decades right so do you all know
where bioinformatics was born
and who gave birth to bioinformatics in
the world
yes that is true since dna model that's
correct so do you all know where
bioinformatics was born who gave which
country or which
continent uh gave birth to
bioinformatics since human genome
project or unifraud
general that's correct usa okay usa
is corrupt yeah so
swiss institute of bioinformatics okay
that's in geneva
so we so a lot of you are saying it's
usa
is that is that what you all think uh
that bioinformatics was born in usa
is that what you all think yes actually
that is correct
i would actually spend a lot of time but
you already all of you actually got the
correct answer right away yes
bioinformatics
actually was born in the usa but do you
all know where in the usa
which state in the usa gave birth to
bioinformatics any idea
san diego okay yes most people actually
guess california as
a reason and i'm not sure why washington
dc
okay um man's institute wow
sasta kumar you have actually come you
have actually you know
taken away the thrill where the uniprot
was initiated okay
so bioinformatics as um
sasha kumar said is actually born at
georgetown university i'm actually very
proud to
say that um and and the tribute
of that goes to uh someone called robert
head
lilly he actually died in 2012
uh from uh from actually alzheimer's
disease sadly
and he is a the person who actually
invented the whole body ct scan as well
the first ct scanner as well
and he also published a book a way
before my time as well
reasoning foundations of medical that
led to computers so i in
in the 50s he already said
you know what he was a visionary he
already said computers are going to lead
the world
and computer and he is the person
who identified the person who gave
birth to the field of bioinformatics
do you all know who actually gave birth
of course now we all have come
bioinformatics was born at georgetown
university
and bioinformatics do you know who the
person
is who actually gave birth and was
officially declared
as the visionary for bioinformatics
anyone knows the name of this person
uh who came up with uh the field who
takes the credit
for coming up and giving birth to
bioinformatics at georgetown university
any guesses this person once i tell you
the name you're going to say oh yeah i
know this person this person has done
lots and lots of other things as well
right yes absolutely sasha kumar you are
answering all my questions
yes you're correct um right yes it is
margaret dehoff right
so uh margaret de hoff is the person
who gave birth to bioinformatics and
she came up with uh yes actually uniprot
was also initiated one of the
uh pioneers of initiation of
um uniproto also existed at georgetown
university
so in the 1950s and 1960s right
she came up with the first atlas of
protein sequence and structure
information
in the 60s where bioinformatics was
actually published in a book
so all the sequences of hemoglobin or
myoglobin
or any sequence that you want to know
you actually
they used to mail this book to everyone
right
so she also has contributed
significantly to other things so she
is the person in the 60s
said that you know what we're going to
have a huge amount of data coming so we
need to create databases so she actually
was the person who came up with a
concept of databases
and believe it or not she is the person
who actually came up with a single
letter
code for amino acids glycine
you just simply write gene alanine you
simply write
a right so there are so many amino acids
simple
single letter code lean you simply write
we right so she's the person who came up
with a single letter and there is a big
story
in the intro interest of time i'm not
going to go through that story
that's one at the time right so she's
the person who came up the court
because in the 60s like you're all
working with a
cell phone right with gigabytes of data
you can do computation on
cell phones right now right but there in
the 60s they did not have enough
computing power
they all that they had was kilobytes and
megabytes of
data storage space so she had to come up
with an intelligent way to store huge
amounts of data right so
so from dna to genome right so these are
all the milestone in the field of
bioinformatics right so i think someone
here said i think was
i'm not sure was it ahmed i'm not sure
who said 1953 yes
uh watson and craig came up with
the dna model and then we have saying
the sequences
was sequence right and uh and then
saying a singer came up with all of
these things right so
sequence alignments came up in the 70s
and protein data bank where structures
were stored we will actually you will be
learning about protein data bank
and then gene bank databases all of this
from
dna to genome these are all the landmark
discoveries that led to the field of
bioinformatics
as it stands today right so all of you
said
that bioinformatics is not in your field
and you are correct bioinformatics is
not a new field
but the term bioinformatics was coined
in the 90s
and so the first time bioinformatics
came in the literature was sometime in
the 90s
although all the discoveries and
everything was made starting in the 50s
and now
it's recognized as a field and it's
recognized as a field
that no one can escape all of us need to
learn this language of
informatics right to move forward so all
of these are seminal
contributions to the field so this was
one of the biggest
contributions is the human genome
initiative
to understand what you and me
are made up of so once you understand
what you're made of we can solve all the
diseases and the problems right
so ncbi national center for
biotechnology information
still stands today as the universal hub
of bioinformatics in the world every
person
goes to ncbi to get information about
sequences or structures or
or or sequencing data anything you want
you go to ncbi
right so it still remains as the hub for
ncbi
and i came into the world of
bioinformatics
when i started working at ncbi right
so some of these things are personal to
me because i worked at ncbi
and that's how i learned many things and
this field i was introduced when i
worked and i actually work
worked and work for uniprot as well so
that is
where i started appreciating uh what
this field is all about and how much you
can use
this field and without knowing all of
these resources whether you want to be a
bench scientist or anything you still
need to know the language of informatics
right so
pasta and blast is a tool i'm sure all
of you have
used blast all of you know what blast is
we'll actually be using that tool as
well right so these are all some of the
seminal
contributions in the field and all of
these things
initiated or to that explosion that
caused
it right so so the origin of
bioinformatics in databases the first
protein sequence that was reported was
insulin in the 50s and sanger was the
one who sequenced
uh and he won the nobel prize for
sequencing insulin in the 50s right
but in the 50s what we did was it took
like 10 years to sequence insulin
although it's a very small protein
right and then it was like one
base after base he was sequencing
imagine
we have hundreds of co with 19 sequences
right now
right and that's how we know that there
are lots of different variants
and if a patient comes down with we know
exactly whether they're having the delta
variant or they're having the alpha
variant
how do we know that we know that because
we're able to sequence things
in a very short amount of time in the
50s
it took 10 years 15 years or 20 years
to come up with sequencing right one
basis a time now we have hypo
height throughput next generation
sequencing
right huge amounts of data can be
produced within fraction within an hour
or
10 minutes or 15 minutes right so that's
where we have come we come from
sequencing that took 20 years to
sequencing that just takes an hour or so
right so very quickly so nearly a decade
later the first nucleated sequence was
sequenced then a major event happened
that was to change the course of human
history right so it was a joint
british and american effort and it was a
race who will complete first
race tests not whether they have taken
the drugs or what
but it was the human genome that was
actually sequenced in 2003
since 2003 once the human genome
sequence was sequenced
that we know yes exactly agp human
genome project that's correct right so
the whole human genome was sequenced
that means do we know
every bit of protein and dna that is
existing within
us do you think that the sequencing has
given us
more data actually yes the this human
genome project
was the start of everything that we are
seeing the data explosion that we are
seeing today
right so for a detailed history of this
we we may not have time to go through
that you can go to this website
this sequencing of the human genome
project it
ended up to be one of the biggest
breakthroughs in the history of
humanity i would say right that got all
of us started in this new
learning this new language and using it
secure understanding diseases and it has
actually given birth to a
huge number of many many disciplines
right
now i'm telling you that the human
genome project
is completed in 2003. we have the
sequence of the human genome
does it mean that we know every single
thing that we need to know about the
humans what do you think do we know
everything we need to know about
ourselves
because of this human genome it's 2003
right it's almost like 16
17 or 18 years ago but today we still
are all diseases do we understand all
diseases today what do you think
have you cured all the diseases no we
have not right we've learned a lot
but we still don't we still have we
still have a long
way to go we are able to understand many
things but yes that is correct right we
don't
that answer is correct yeah and i'll
tell you why
we don't have not solved the mystery of
human
diseases even covet right we are in kobe
for a year and a half almost
do we have a cure for covet the entire
world is looking at one problem of
trying to find a therapeutic for covet
we don't
but thanks to science thanks to the
human genome project
we have a vaccine we have a successful
vaccine
that is extremely efficacious and
how are we able to come up with the
vaccine within a course of one year
it's thanks to the advancement in
technology thanks to the unwanted
advancement and understanding of the
human genome right so we understand that
and that's why we're able to make
progress
but do we know everything no we don't
know there are lots of challenges and
those are the challenges that i'm going
to talk to you right
at the conclusion of the human genome
project right so
complete sequencing it has generated a
new branch
of science and medicine and which is
called the genomics right
so what did we learn from the human
genome what did we learn we learned
that the human genome project sequence
is completed and it contains of course
approximately 3.2 billion base pairs
right
so we have all of these things right so
we know that we're very complex
and then once the human genome project
was completed
more and more and more genomes were
sequenced we have the mouse genome or
some of them actually that sequence even
before the human genome
we have mosquito genome we have the rad
genome we have the chicken genome we
have the plants genome
we have lots of these microbial genomes
right so
once the human genome was solved we
still went ahead
and solved lots and lots of genomes and
the reason to solve
lots of other genomes is to do
comparative genomics right
how does human genome compare to a mouse
how does human genome compare to a
chicken right
because even the vaccine right we have
to test it
in some other animal we cannot put a
test
vaccine in a human right so we have to
do testing
whether something is working or not and
for that we need to figure out
what is a good model to use for testing
right
so the asterisk zanika vaccine was
tested in a monkey
right because monkeys and chimp right
they're closest
to the human so if it works in a chimp
it will work in a human
so we really need to understand just not
human we need to understand other
organisms so that we can do comparative
genomics right
but we are we are facing a lot of
challenges
because of the sequencing of all of
these right so we have lots and lots of
bases we have lots of lots of sequences
that are coming from environment we have
lots of sequences
uh in uniprot kb stands for knowledge
base
these are sequences of proteins and then
we have
proteins are divided into domains
smaller
fractions that's what does the function
and we will learn a lot of these things
over and over again through the course
of this week so you will understand all
of this by end of this week right so
we have lots of three-dimensional
structures we have lots of families of
proteins
and all of these things right so at the
end of the day to summarize
we are all going to deal with a huge
amount of data explosion
right so that's all we are so once we
have data how do we use the data
right so we have to create data basis
that holds all of this data right now
once we have the data we have to put
them in form of databases so you and me
can use this databases right amazon is a
database
right you go through different databases
right so you go through the database
behind it and then once you have it in a
database
then using tools we can extract
knowledge
right so these databases are knowledge
bases
right these are the ones that are used
in genome analysis
and you are going to learn a lot of
different databases
and the tools to in order to extract
knowledge from all of these databases
right
so you have lots of molecular biology
databases right
dna sequence databases and all of these
things right so
these are all the different databases
you have lots of data but you also have
increasing amount of databases as well
right now this all of this data
has given births to the era of ohms
and omega era in biology right
so this is all of you probably know
this central dogma of molecular biology
and you can actually
translate this into omics right
at the end of the day it all starts with
the genome right
dna then the dna becomes rna
and then the rna becomes protein and the
protein has to
fold into the structures
three-dimensional structures
in order to be able to do its function
right
so each one of this can be translated
into an omic term right so now let's do
that right
so this is the core of bioinformatics
right
so dna right so then
you have the rna right dna gets
transcribed
to an rna mrna right messenger rna and
then a copic vaccine
is an mrna vaccine right it actually is
against the mrna that codes for a
protein
then this codes for a protein and then
this falls into a structure
and then we understand the functions in
the context of
metabolism meta metabolites and
metabolism and all of those things now
i want you to help me here can you
translate dna to anomic term
what is the tria what ohmic term
describes a dna
can can any of you put it in the chart
so if you translate
this into an omic term what would that
be
yes absolutely fantastic um anushka
right so dna is strong is genomics right
the
all the data from dna is translated to
genomics what is all the omics for
uh for rna right wiki that is correct
i'm going to wait for a second we
we are going to do first rna and then
we'll get to the proteins right
proteins is proteomics absolutely
correct yes
rna is transcriptomics absolutely
fantastic
and structure there is not uh a form
term i came up with the term and i
called it i call it structural mix
right and now people are using it in the
literature as well so i just refer to
structure as structural structuromics
right and
function is metabolomics that's correct
general
metabolites is metabolomix right for
function
absolutely correct now function
is also functionomics right determining
from structure is functionomics right so
it's also again
this is a term that's being used so now
you can understand what is
bioinformatics
bioinformatics is combining
all of this omics together right from
dna to understand at the end of the day
all of us are interested in
understanding functions right
so we want to understand functions if we
don't understand functions we cannot
solve the problem of biology
right we have to understand how how
everything is working the spike protein
and covariate i'm i keep repeating
covalent because that's
where we are living in right now and all
of you can relate to kovic so that's why
keep bringing up covet right
so spike protein is the most important
protein
in in that's why we have to understand
the function of that spike protein
and that's when we can actually create
vaccines we can create therapeutics rate
so all of this is translating into omics
and this is where all the huge amount of
data that
defines bioinformatics of course i'm not
put all the ohmic terms here
right that there are a lot more ohmic
terms within this that exist within this
right i'm just giving
you the big picture right we have
genomics proteomics and all of those
things right
and anomics means unknown if there is
lots of things that we still don't
know and we club that all into genomics
anomics or whatever it is so these are
all the other omics right
interactomics glycomics and
all of this lots and lots more ohmic
terms right so
and structural mix right so now we
went through a formal definition of
bioinformatics if you all remember right
it's
data processing data collection getting
information from it
getting knowledge out of it but now now
that i
i told you a different way of looking at
bioinformatics
do you think we can come up with a
different definition for bioinformatics
that encompasses
all of this omex charms right so
i came up with something myself right
and there is a new definition of
bioinformatics and my
new definition of bioinformatics is
all of this right so bioinformatics
encompasses
a lot of different aspects of omics
right functionomics
proteomics metabolomics in fact even
mathematics we need math in order to be
able to calculate different things
interlactomics so i keep changing this
over and this also can be used for
defining systems
biology as well right so to me this is
a simpler definition of bioinformatics
and this is my definition do you all
think you can fill this
up for me just guess
what is the definition this is just for
fun so
what can in a definition of
bioinformatics can actually be
what do you think do you think that you
can fill this
any guesses from
what i just told you
any guesses
identification good uh identification
it's actually a good
um good guess i d
i d e n that door identification doesn't
fit here but although you are correct
can actually next time i should think
about that so this is actually
interaction let's see i n t e r
a c d i
o n o my goodness interaction
interpretation oh my god you came up
with something else
guys oh integration that's correct so
integration of ohmic terms honestly
i think gerald and reynolds i am going
to write down your
definition because you know what that
also fits here and you are
correct right interpretation
probably doesn't so i'm going to write
down for future amazing amazing so you
have given me a new definition so it's
either integration
of ohmic terms or interaction between
all different ohmic terms i love that
fantastic so my new definition is
simpler
it's pretty much you all agree with me
so it's just an integration of formic
terms right
so now sequence analysis is actually
very very important so we have lots and
lots of millions of sequences in public
databases
we have more data in in other
proprietary
um thank you so completion of more
genome so what right so
in all of these sequences what you can
find
in all of these sequences something that
is hidden right you can just from the
sequence
it has huge amounts of structural
functional and evolutionary information
it's all
hidden in the sequence we just have to
learn
how to pull up that lecture that
information that is hidden in these
sequences out
and make use of that meaningful right so
there's all these sequences and
resources are very valuable to us
right and there are lots of structures
as well right so there's there's
all of these sequences are very very
important and that form the foundational
principles for the
by for bioinformatics right just from
the sequence we are going to if we i'm
going to show you
how you can extract the function of the
sequences how can you extract the
structure of the sequences
how can you extract and put them
together and go and understand
how a single mutation is causing a
disease right
that's what it's going to be fascinating
just because from the see everything is
in within the sequence
you just have to learn some tools and
resources so that you understand how
to manipulate that and understand and
it's like
decoding it's like a puzzle right it's
literally like a puzzle
you just have to find and decode things
now we are still far away from actually
solving a human puzzle of the human
genome right we still are far away
but we're getting inching closer and
closer to understanding at least
that things are very complex right so so
now
what's in a sequence right so you have
huge amount of
structural information you have
functional information
right and what you immediately
understand
if sequences are very similar to each
other
and you this is called an alignment you
align sequences row by row
and if you find that they look alike
this
look alike and then there are regions
that are highly conserved right this if
you look at this column
in every sequence and all of these
sequences may be from different
organisms right so this sequence may be
from human
this sequence may be from a mouse this
sequence may be from a plant
this sequence may be from a worm this
sequence may be from a bacteria
but yet if you put them all together
there are things that are common between
them right that's what we do
when we will start saying oh my god this
sequence from a mouse and this sequence
from a human
are very close to each other so they
have to have a similar function that's
how we actually correlate and come up
with things so this is so just this
sequence contains
everything and if you're all able to
you're all very very smart
and you all can decode this very easily
and you will win a nobel prize right to
find out simple methodologies of coming
up with
different things right so i'm sure that
think think
and keep an open mind and a anyone can
win
anything right anyone can do all of this
right so
now perfect timing right so this is i
this is it's actually an hour i'm it's
amazing so what i have done to just
summarize
all i have done in the last one hour is
data right there's so much of data we
defined what bioinformatics is and we
also understood
that sequencing the human project was
the first
thing that gave rise to so many ohms and
omics
era eye biology and now we are looking
at the central dogma of molecular
biology
from the eyes of data right so we
converted the central dogma of biology
to meaningful terms like genomics
transcriptomics proteomics and all of
those things right so omic
era so this is the summary right for the
first thing now i'm going to pause for a
second
and see if any of you have any questions
and then we can move on to the next
aspect of
why we are drowning in and just because
the human
project genome was solved we have come a
long way
but we still have longer ways to go
and when the human genome project came
we all celebrated
right we all went oh my god oh my god
now we know everything about the human
genome
we can actually solve all the diseases
we can find cures for all the diseases
but after 17 years we still don't right
so i'm going to tell you from the human
genome project
what else happened and where we are
today for the next part of the lecture
now i'm going to pause for a second and
see if any of you have any questions
do you all i have any questions
if not i can just um okay so it's
interactively refers to branches
relationshipity nodes in um
so yes that's actually just curious
absolutely it's a fantastic question
gerald and
in fact you know what i'm going to be
talking about a little bit about
uh interactive links in the context of
three dimensional structures tomorrow if
if we all meet again tomorrow i'm not
sure so right so
it all depends on you guys right so how
uh how interesting i made this lecture
for you today just
to make sure that you all come back
tomorrow i'm not sure how many of you
are going to come back tomorrow
but interacto mix is interactions
you're absolutely correct it is actually
interrelationship
between metabolites not only necessarily
metabolites but between
proteins that actually produce these
metabolites
right so if you if in a given pathway
right
so you have many different steps right
so step one protein in step one or an
enzyme interacts with one thing in step
two
so the interaction between those two
protein
has led to the whole world of
interactomics what which protein
interacts with what
and and upstream and downstream yes you
are correct long story short
you are absolutely correct that's what
interact interactomics actually is a
summary of
interactions in a given pathway
right so any other questions
oh yes muhammad has a question i i see a
uh
um ahmed as uh raising his hand so
um is he able to unmute i'm not sure
muhamed
or uh
oh yes i'll just unmutely
yes muhammad you can unmute yourself now
i think
okay i think he's not here maybe
um or you can actually maybe put your
question in the chat
um
oh
i don't know okay so i'm going to
continue and uh muhammad can
um ask his question on a chat or i can
you know
we can talk later so if there are no
other questions i'm just going to
move to the next part where we're going
to talk about that we are all in an era
of big data right
so so diseases that's what we're all
interested in
so diseases and manifestations of
something that's gone wrong
in a gene right so if something gets
mutated
right so here you see that everything
all the sequences
ah share with the selection so we will
be sharing the
recorded video with you we will not be
sharing the slides
we will be sharing the recorded video
that actually shows you all the slides
okay so here you have or this if you
look at this
um this column right you see all of them
are glycines here and suppose i mutate
one amino acid here since this is highly
conserved
this is going to depending on what this
g is mutated too
it could lead to a change in
its structure and change in function
right so
um so diseases are a manifestation of
something that's gone wrong
with amman amino acid in a protein right
so
the pieces inside of you that make you
who you are
all is you have a this is the whole
genome
and then you are we all have chromosomes
right then within which we have the
genes
and then there are lots of genes and
between two genes
of course you have the intronic region
or introgenic right so
uh and during the process of the um
central dogma right so
all of these centrogenic regions are
removed and the genes are connected to
each other right so you have the genome
then you have the dna that codes for
your genes right so it has genes
in them and these genes code for
proteins
right and these are the ones that
actually have biological functions in
the sub
and all of the proteins have to fold
into three dimensions right so
if you look at the whole genome the
fascinating point of the genome
is that the genome is organized in a
very
disciplined manner and every single
protein
has a specific function that it has to
do
not only it has a specific function but
it also has to do
its function at a specific time
during the process right so if it's
doing things
out of its turn that's when something
goes wrong right because the cell is not
used to this particular protein showing
up when it's not supposed to show up
and proteins when they work outside of
their turn
the cell doesn't know so that's when you
know and some proteins get ex those
proteins get expressed
in different cells right you don't have
a
heart cell in your kidneys or you don't
have a kidney cell in a lungs
but when you do find those in different
organs then there is a problem right if
there is a protein that has to be
each organ has its own function right so
your heart muscle
right it has some proteins that makes
your heart
pump and all of those things specific
things have specific functions
in your body and in the cell each and
every cell has the same number of
proteins and the same genome but
some proteins are expressed only in
certain organs right the kidneys there
are
specific proteins that work to make the
kidneys there are specific proteins that
genes get expressed in the heart and hot
muscles right
but sometimes when these wrongly
get turned on in other organs when
they're not supposed to get turned on
that's when you start getting diseases
because they are supposed they're not
supposed to be there
they're in the wrong wrong place at the
wrong time and so
it creates problems for the sun right so
so everything so the human genome
project right so it has transformed that
the way we think about diseases right
we have learnt a lot of different things
right so what we have learned
is from a dna right replication
dna and then you have transcription
again i'm repeating the central dogma
and then rna produces proteins right
translation at the end of the day
amino acids and then proteins then the
amino acids are produced
into a stretch stretch of amino acids
they have to fold in a specific manner
in order to reduce proteins and then the
proteins have a specific structure
in three dimensions and then these
proteins
fall within given pathways right so this
is the genome
and this is the genotype and then
this is uh i have not blurred the slides
i didn't change anything at
all um yeah i'm not changed anything at
all actually
um i'm not sure um
everything is fine on our side maybe uh
the one who's asking
uh might have some poor net connectivity
that can be a reason on your end yes
yeah it may be um yeah
it's fine okay so uh hopefully here i
think maybe the internet connection and
once it
saw it probably will resolve itself okay
so
from a genotype and this is what
is the phenome or the phenotype right so
phenotype is what we actually see right
you have a cold you have a headache you
have
pain um and that is the phenotype that's
what you're actually feeling right but
you don't know what has gone wrong
inside there's something that's gone
wrong inside
in the genome that is actually making
you
cause having a headache you have a
migraine that is a phenotype
all the effect is all phenotype right
genotype is the one that
actually causes has the changes but the
one
what manifests itself is the phenotype
right so
um and so now diseases there are lots
and lots of diseases right so they're
classified into
monogenic disease it's like sickle cell
anemia i'm sure all of you have heard of
sickle cell anemia right so we're going
to be talking a lot about sickle cell
anemia
and sickle cell anemia is and is a very
simple in a sense it's a monogenic
disease it's not a simple disease but
it's a monogenic disease which
means there is a mutation in one
just one single gene and one
amino acid has changed in that gene
mono means one right genic is gene right
so there is one
single mutation in a gene in one gene
and that causes a disease
right and the disease is sickle cell
anemia
now there are lots of complex diseases
which are polygenic diseases which means
there are changes in
lots and lots that's correct well into a
glutamic acid right or a glutamic acid
to availing i always forget the
combination but we're going to we're
going to study that in depth
um so polygenic disease means there are
lots of genes that are affected
giving rise to the disease so it makes
the disease very complex
right very difficult right to understand
so we have single
monogenic diseases and then we have
polygenic diseases and then we also have
chromosomal disorders right
so a child is having a problem
at birth the child is born already with
a syndrome called the down syndrome yeah
thank you
um and so genomic disorders right so
chromosomal disorders right so there is
a problem with the gene there is an
extra chromosome
and and the baby is born with a disease
already so these are all chromosomal
disorders
where you know it's there is nothing we
can do about them right because it's
it's already the baby is born with the
proboscimal
aberrations but now with crispr cast 9
with all the technological advancements
maybe
we can find uh we can fix all of that
in in the near future in the next decade
or so right
and then we also have lots of
environmental diseases infectious
diseases right like
ebola and covada all of them are
infectious diseases right so
and now the old genetics right the
monogenetics it so what
we thought before the the era before the
whole genome
sequencing right about conditions that
are holy caused by an extra or missing
chromosome are part of the chromosome
say down syndrome turner syndrome and
all of these syndromes
or mutations in every in a specific gene
like cystic fibrosis or morphine
syndrome
you're all going to if you actually
continue with the with the course and
you are going to do a project you will
be picking one of these diseases to be
able to go and look
and and understand right is it possible
to correct down symptoms postpone
so um at this point yeah i would say
no um it is it you can only manage the
symptoms and make
uh life little better but cure
not yet not yet not yet but i am hopeful
that
i'm not sure with all the technologies
are such as that right
so now the conditions are of great
importance to individuals and families
with them but even when added together
are relatively rare right so down
syndromes are very rare
and 20 to 30 years ago you know we won't
even hear about it we won't even know
about this
in the hospitals you won't even have a
genetic counselor who's going to counsel
you
and all of them right but now genetics
plays a very big role
it used to play a small role because not
many people were affected we didn't know
about it
but now because of the human genome
project we know a lot about it right so
these are all some of the examples of
monogenic diseases
now do you all understand what monogenic
diseases mean monogenic diseases mean
that there is only one gene that is
affected
with one single mutation in that
particular gene
is called monogenic diseases majority of
the diseases unfortunately are
complex diseases right so a very few
hormoneogenic diseases right so we still
have a lot of monogenic diseases that
we're able to understand much better
and a cure as possible for those
monogenic diseases right so the new
genetics and genomics
that came from the human genome project
right and the genetics
is the future is now right now what we
have learned from the human genome
project
is that we have a 3.2 basis that's
packaged into a chromosome 3.2 billion
base pairs
and then the mitochondria itself can
exist alone
it has 16 600 and the human genome
project
of course it was initiated in the 90s
and then it took a long
time before we got the sequence and it
took a long time
is because we didn't have technological
advancements with
sequencing and that's why it took a long
time for it to be sequenced right so
and of course the sequence are finished
ahead of time because they ran out of
money is the story i'm hearing
right now how does a human genome stack
up right so
a mouse has twenty thousand to twenty
two thousand so you have a
round worm you have fruit flies you have
these
all of this have so many genes right so
now
how many genes do you think that humans
actually have
what is your yes pick one
option let's see whether you're able to
get this right so how many genes do we
actually have
any guesses you can just guess b okay
c okay c okay see
that's what a lot of you are saying 35
000
a b okay some b's a lot of c's actually
right a lot of c's and some b's let's
find out so
oops sorry it's not c again
it does not c but let's see if it is b
a okay a let's see a
oops no let's try b
and it is b so
what we have is we have we still don't
know the exact
number but we have anywhere between 20
000
um 500 to 21 000 or 22 000 we still
don't know exactly we are still
continuing to sequence believe me or not
after 17 years
we are still sequencing because we are
there are some chromosomes that are very
complex we are still
sequencing we don't have an accurate
number
but we kind of know that we are not as
complex
as we thought we were and those of you
who picked
option c your you that was the guess
that we would have made
when early days of the sequencing we
thought that we are going to come up
with 50
000 genes or 35 000 genes because how
can a small
animal like a rat i have 20 000 mv
also how can we have not have more than
there are
right so we thought that we are going to
have 50 000 and then that estimate
dropped down to 35 000 in the middle of
sequencing and then finally we were
shocked
to understand yes as per they have they
assumed it was 30 000
uh but then uh you know we we have
i guess there are some graph regions as
well and complexity complexity
but we don't we are not as complex in
terms of the number of
genes but we are still complex right
so um so here we have that's why we use
and we are actually uh we are very very
close to a mouse genome so we are almost
like 99 percent similar with a mouse
genome that's why mouse and
rats are being used as model uh
sorry so phenotypes phenomes means
phenotype which is like headache
whatever the effects of a gene mutation
is called the phenotype right so genome
genotype is a gene phenotype is the
effect of the gene on you
right so if you have a mutation in uh
you know
you you in in type 2 diabetes people
with type 2 diabetes right they have
fatigue and they have you know those are
the phenotypes right the effect
of the mutation is the queen of any
disease is a phenotype right
so now these are also a round worm has
19 000 so you know what so
although we are very close in the number
of genes with a mouse
right so but we still are not a mouse
right we still are very very complex and
i'll tell you why
we are complex right so the new genetics
is
virtually all diseases x has a genetic
component
right this is how it happened right in
2000
we just understood a gene that was
implicated
in type 2 diabetes and keep looking
at this right so because of the human
genome project we started understanding
more and more and more
genes got sequenced and this i should
change this to 2021
and finally we understand that today
we understand a lot about what genes are
involved in different diseases
and we thought that we are at a stage
that we can just say right a real
disease a real gene please stand up
right we thought we'll be able to solve
all the problems of all diseases but we
actually don't unfortunately we don't
right
so what do you think that we are still
complex although we have only
um you know 20 000 genes right
but we are still complex and we have
identified
more than a lot of genes involved in a
disease right so
curated means experimentally validated
people have done
experiments to show that yes this gene
is implicated in sickle cell in anemia
yes this gene is implicated in
alzheimer's yes this gene is implicated
in crohn's disease
so curation means that there is an
experimental determination that that
particular gene is implicated
in that particular disease right so what
do you think how many genes do we have
that we know for sure or involved
in a disease we are going to do this
when we do the hands-on part using
uniprot dynamics i'll show you how to
pull up this number
so just take a wild guess even you know
this is just more for fun right so b
oh because i kept keeping my cursor on
b ahmad says d so let's see
no amit no c okay so that's not c
so it's actually b we have
so we are going to actually um
do this in by handsaw right so we have
about
actually this number maybe a little bit
more because i have not updated the
slide in some time so maybe it is a
little bit more we'll find out using
uniprot we'll find out right
so from genes to proteins right so
we are going from genes to proteins and
so how many protein products do you
think we have
so we have established yeah precision
medicine that's absolutely correct at
all that's what i do for a living
general i do precision medicine
so now i told you that we have
20 close to 20 to 21 000 genes right
each gene produces proteins right
proteins are coming from genes
correct so how many proteins do we have
in our
cells how many proteins do you have b
ah okay so uh the via that and that is
what i would have guessed as well right
that is what i
because you know what i was taught when
i went to school
right that one gene produces one protein
right so one gene produces one protein
right but that is what i need but now
you know what has happened we have
changed the definition of a gene one
gene produces
more than one protein right that's why
we are black back on the square board
and that we are very very complex
so although we have the same number of
genes all if you say b yes
actually d is the correct answer
although
you know we have only 21 000 genes we
are very complex
although we have the same number of
genes as a mouse we are not a mouse
but if we're very very complex right we
don't want to be like a mouse correct so
so what has happened is we have changed
the definition of a gene
in the last 10 years or so that a gene
codes for a polypeptide
right so there are so many things it's
not
unnecessarily operands general so it is
actually
alternatively and um
quite honestly this hundred thousand may
actually be a underestimate
i have to go double check maybe we have
a million protein products some people
believe that we
probably have a million protein products
right but
this may be an underestimate of that the
reason is because we have lots of
alternatively spliced forms the gene can
be alternative yes kriti that's correct
ultimately splicing because of alternate
splicing
a gene produces more than one product
right so we are going to we are going to
look into all of this
when we are doing the hands off right so
um that's correct so
um so what we have learned although you
know we have learnt a lot right now
right poly genes
well you know i'm not sure whether it is
called polygenes but i think we are
learning more about pseudogenes we don't
know if something
is a gene or it's not a gene so we have
lots of pseudo gene
and we have lots of iso forms right
all of these gene products that are
coming from an
alternatively splice alternative
splicing
are actually called isoforms right we
will actually go through that right
so to just to summarize i'm repeating
myself over and over again because some
of your very new so that you know
repeating actually you know this
you feel like it is thinking and what
i'm trying to tell you right humans are
fewer protein coding genes than expected
and then only 1.5 percent of this human
genome is involved in coding for
proteins did you know that
we us we have spent the last
20 30 years or more or 50 years
studying only 1.5 percent
of our genome right so
we have a whole six feet genome and we
are only looking at the genes
that codes for protein and the genes
that code for protein is only 1.5
percent of your genome
right so we have spent the last 50 years
looking at that
but i wouldn't say of course in the last
10 15 years we have learnt that right so
what have we learned about ourselves
that humans are not
and mice have about the same number but
we are not we are different right so
we have that's what i just covered right
so who's our closest relative our
closest relative is a chimpanzee
we how close are we among ourselves we
are actually
99.9 percent very close to each other
yet we are different right so
to do it there are so many differences
between two patients who have the same
disease
right now we are still different
although we have our human genome
but we are still different from each
other we are very close we are 99.9
percent similar but we are still
different right so
we some of us like sweet some of us like
salty food some of us you know i'm just
making it very simple right
and two people having the same disease
if you give one this
you give the same drug it works in one
it does not work in the other
right why so we were all puzzled
right so we thought after the human
genome was solved
we thought problem solved we can cure
every single disease
come on let's make the therapeutics like
let's come up with drugs for the
tied to that let's come up with drugs
for everything let's cure our diseases
that's it no more diseases but that's
not what happened right we learned a lot
from the human genome project but that
did not solve our mystery
of any of the diseases right so
then it came with a lot of promises
right so
it said okay you're going to become
you're going to you you're going to be
young
forever i like that right i don't like
it at all right so
and then but what happened was in
reality
what we found sorry what we found was
two patients with the same symptom same
finding same disease
and you give the same drug and
they have different side effects right
lack of efficacy
at the recommended prescribed dose they
have some
some of it is harmful some of it is like
even when you look at the covert right
some people have mild microwave disease
some people have very severe cover
disease and even with the vaccine
i did i had lots of side effects from
the vaccine my husband had no effects at
all it was almost like he didn't even
take the vaccine
right so why two people we are reacting
differently
even though our genomes are 99.9 percent
similar right
so orthologs um generally i'm going to
come with uh
orthologs so orthologs are um not
because of
orthologs i would say more
i if at all you want to go that route i
would more say more paralogs because
orthologs are the same protein in
different
organisms right paralogs are the ones
within the same organisms right so
but what it is i'm going to give you the
answer to that question in a second hold
on to that right so
so people react differently to drugs
right so
what happens is people some people have
toxicity some people and all of those
things
and we did not understand why what is
going on with all of these things
right so what it is is there is
difference in ethnicity
difference in age difference in genetic
factors different
drug drug interactions so all of it
is we are all similar 99.5
nine percent but you know what we are
still 0.1 percent different between each
other correct
so we said you know what we have to look
at that point
one yes lifestyle actually is very very
important too all of that
and now something is like microbiome
right even the bugs that is within you
that's
beyond the scope for this course but
there are lots of other things as well
right
so what is next right so we saw the
human genome project but then you know
we said you know what
in order to understand and solve this
problem
we have to understand the the
point one percent of 0.5 percent that is
different
between all of us right so that was what
was the hapmap project
then they we we said okay we are going
to look at all the polymorphisms that
exist
between the human population and then
after the polymorphism it still did not
solve the problem
right so i'll tell you that right now
today
we have to understand the entire human
genome to be able to solve the puzzle
that's what that's where we are today
right we have to solve the entire human
genome understand the coding regions
understand the non-coding regions and
it's ongoing ongoing
you know what it's going to be beyond my
my life beyond
your lives as well the next 20 30
50 years but one thing assured that
informatics is a field
that's going to stay and that is what is
going to become
like a field that all of us need to know
and we all need to know this language
right you have to know this because the
next 20 30 years we have enough data
to be able to figure out how to solve
all of these problems right that's why
we have all of them
so half map yes um as i'm going to
repeat hapmap in a second sasa i'm going
to go into details
right i'm just going to go into details
in the next few slides i'm going to
explain what that is so what
is happening project right so my project
is of course there are lots of other
um yeah i'm going to come back to app my
project but there are lots if
the slide doesn't i'm going to explain
it again to you right so
these are all the other um you know
genome projects because
we are going to keep doing this until we
solve the problem now you know what is
the newest
we're going to we're looking at the bugs
that is within us we are sequencing the
microbiome
so now no matter one of you may actually
put all of this together and solve the
problem for us right so we never know so
keep an open mind
keep doing your things and ask questions
and learn a lot
because you may come up with a solution
right you may come up with a complete
solution right so
um sequencing projects so now i'm going
to come up with what is hack my project
right
what is hapmap is so you all know
mutations right there is an amino acid
change but then there is another term
called variation
right these variations means there's one
nucleotide that is changing right one
nucleotide that is changing
and at the dna level and this nucleotide
change
is actually a causing a change in the
protein
right so hackmap project is a project
that helps us understand diseases and
why some respond and others because we
are identifying
polymorphism that is it is actually
a difference nucleotide base pair
difference between
you and me and everyone else right so
it is actually creates diversity in
human population
just imagine the whole world was with
just one genetics
that's it right it won't be interesting
everybody is the same everybody reacts
the same
and anyway this is what is diversity
because
we are not the same right even if you're
coming from
the same ethnic population i am indian
i'm from india right so even if i
compare myself with some of you who are
from india
we may be very different right because
of so many factors that we are learning
now
environmental factors nutritional
factors and genetic factors
polymorphisms right so that's what this
hapmap project is about how
how many of these variations are there
in that point five percent of the gene
right so so this is single nucleotide
polymorphism there is this single means
one nucleotide you know that right it's
a base right so one nucleotide change
right so
it is a correlation that so what are
snips
snips are defined as one this is your
dna
snip is something where there is just
one
base has changed and then this
sometimes this base change may not lead
to a change in your protein amino acid
sometimes this base may change the
protein like in sickle cell anemia it
has changed
right the base change has changed the
amino
acid when an amino acid change then that
it changes the protein changes protein
changes the structure changes
right structure changes function changes
yes change in a nucleotide right
so snips are very common in the human
population between any two people that
is an average of one sniff for every
thousand base pairs most of these are no
phenotypic effect which means you and me
may have lots of changes but we don't
know that we have the change because
it's not affecting us in any way
right so less than one percent of the
human snips
affect the function right so so alleles
they're very very important to
understand because their alleles of
health
their genetic markers they're easy to
uh and fast to understand
and they can give us genetic association
in and then it leads to
a new omic term called pharmacogenomics
pharmacogenomics is
all about how drugs how you react to
different medicines or
drugs and all of those things correct
now a map of human genome it produced
believe me or not we
came up with 1.42 million
polymorphisms they sequenced and we
found it right
so now snips can be lead to altered
protein sequence and
protein sequence altering and one base
change
changes the amino acid when the amino
acid changes
it changes the structure of the protein
if the structure changes it changes the
function
of that protein right so mutations
are deleterious snips right inherited
you can inherit a mutation
from your parents right genetic
disorders
right and most of these deleting
variations
affect the functions of the protein
lexical cell anemia valine to glutamic
acid
right and so um and so i think
vicky said that earlier right and so
sickle cell anemia so we are going to be
talking about sickle cell anemia right
it's all about the three-dimensional
structure of the protein this
this is a structure of hemoglobin
this is just that sickle cell this is
the one single mutation
that causes a disease can you believe
that my god just one mutation right
majority of glutamare
well yeah so did i make a mistake on
that slide i'll go and check right
sequence we're going to look at the
structure we're going to look a look at
all of those things right so
sequence genomes of large number of
people you compare the basis like it's
facebook right so you can create
profiles
you group people with the same mutation
and maybe you have to give them a
different drug
and all of these things it's like
facebook profile right you all have
facebooks
and all that right so you create a snip
profile right you can create a profile
based on
what snips you actually have and the
doctors
imagine the doctors can just use that
for the treatment down the road right
for some diseases we are already doing
that
but for most diseases we can down the
road we can actually do that right so
correlations can emerge
based on this right this is an example
if uh of anticoagulated right so if
anyone has a surgery in a hospital
right what happens at the effect of a
surgery is because you're not moving
you will end up getting blood clots
right people who have surgeries in a
hospital they are given
blood thinners so that they don't get
clots
right so you have to keep moving right
if you're not moving and if you're in a
in a surgery you're not moving so they
give what are called
blood thinners now i'm not sure about
different countries
but there is a polymorphism that is
there for dozing
and there is a snip that's been there
for whether someone should get this or
not
right so these are all some of it is
made to the clinic
and some of it will make it to the
clinic so for example i'm indian for
indians we have to have a lower dose of
this warfarin we cannot take the
same dosage as warfarin that is given to
a caucasian
so for me the dosage has to be lower so
they will test whether i have
a snip in any of these two genes yes
thinner
and if i have a snip in any of these two
jeans then what happens is i have to
they have lowered the dose for me
because i'm asian and
indian right so that's what it means
right so all of these things so more
examples
are there you can look at snapedia for
all of these things right so there are
lots of snips that we can look at
and this is going to come in handy for
practicing pharmacogenomics right
genetic profile to predict response to
certain diseases
and the clinical goal is to do better
treatment decisions right so and
there are lots and lots of genetic tests
right now and in fact there are tests
where they can
test whether you have us you have a high
disposition to getting breast cancer if
you come from a family where people are
already have um you know a lot of
members of the family have breast cancer
then you can already
sequence a gene to figure out whether
you have a snip
that they can predict that you may come
down with breast cancer down the road in
your
life right so all of this we have made a
lot of strides we have made a lot thanks
to hapmap project where we are able to
sequence
and get all of these snips right so now
the last projects is of course the end
code project which is the remaining
part 98.5 of the genome right
they when i was in school they used to
be called junk
they used to be called junk dna right
now there is now no more junk in our
genome
every bit of your genome is important
and every bit of your genome contributes
to
your well-being contributes we just have
not figured it out
it is all there but we're not figured
that's what we're going to spend the
next 30 years 20 30 years right
and also genome-wide association they we
have also found yes tudor jones and
we are still learning about serogenes
gerald we still don't know a lot about
them
so genomic association studies is about
ethnic populations so indians react to
drugs differently then
americans react to different and
african-americans so
it's all about ethnicity and populations
food and which part of the world
you are so we will be learning a little
bit about all of these as well right so
all of this has expanded our
understanding about understanding about
diseases
and a small variations happen discovered
numerous diseases
and will definitely all of this we have
to collect it's all like a
puzzle right we all have to put all of
this together
and we have to actually connect all of
these dots together in order to solve
the puzzle
right we are getting there slowly
steadily and more and more
data is actually coming right now big
data it has
produced lots of genes and lots of snips
and lots of diseases right so i have to
and so big data has produced lots of
different
biology data and these are all the
different databases
that we can go to in order to
put some pieces of the puzzle together
and to understand
some of the diseases right so as you go
through the project phase
of this uh you know this course then you
will actually be looking at some of
these databases in order to understand
the disease understand the gene
understand the structure
how to get functions and all of those
things right
now this is the future of genomics it's
already here right if you go to the
doctor
they're going to sequence your genome
they're going to create all of these
and they're going to advise you on
lifestyles and preventions and
screening and all of those things right
this is
what we are doing right now in a lot of
science right this is the future of
medicine right sequencing informatics
data mining and
all of you are going to become experts
to helping if you become
bioinformaticians you're all going to
become
experts assistants to physicians in
order to be able to help them decipher
a genome and all of those things right
so this is what it is
because we know more specific
information we can diagnose
people better and all of those things
and we can eliminate diseases
and we can actually come up with
prognosis early on right so
now this is not the end this is not even
the beginning of the end
but it is perhaps the end of the
beginning when i keep reading this my
head
is reeling over and over because i don't
even know what churchill is supposed
is trying to tell all i think he's
trying to tell is
it is just the beginning right yes there
are lots of information in the
intergenic regions
and lots of snips in the intergenic
regions kia and we don't even know how
to
make sense of them yet right for some we
are able to make sense of it but others
we are still not able to make sense of
it right so
so let's so there is something like you
know if you're all interested
you can take a chromosome walk uh in the
interest of time
you can all do it at your own i can outs
i'm sorry right so
uh you can all you know take a walk of
this chromosomes
and it will tell you that which uh
chromosome i think it probably opened up
somewhere here
um where is that
okay so you can you can you know take a
walk
um and you know so take and
all of those things right so now i'm
just going to show you
that for a second and i'm going to leave
the last 10 minutes
oh i'm going to stop share here
and i'm going to spend the next
10 15 minutes so that we can re revisit
everything that we have talked about so
that you can ask me questions so that it
is all
uh clear to you so this is the
chromosome
walk right so
you can look at it at your favor right
so
ah let's see let's see let's see yeah
right so
now if you click on chromosome one
yeah so it'll tell you this is
chromosome one
right you can learn about what are the
diseases
in chromosome 1 right so it's it's a 23
pairs and if you click here
right so this tells you each one is in
each one of this is a gene right this is
tells you this is a gene that's called
thor's one that will tell you whether
you can you can you know when you taste
something and if it is sweet
oh sharon oh i'm sorry thank you thank
you thank you for letting me know i'm
sorry
um
okay so now i hope you can all see right
so i'm going to go back i'm sorry thank
you for letting me know
um so so this is what you have so if you
click on chromosome 1
right so this is chromosome one it tells
you how many cro you know and if you
click here
right so it tells you which gene
is actually for um
sweet so this gene for example is stars
one
and a mutation in this maybe you won't
be able to say if something is sweet or
not right this is this
gene that is involved in the perception
of sweet
and other tastes so if you have a
problem in ms
and a snip in your this gene
maybe you won't be able to taste it
maybe
in covet right some people use your
taste and smell
maybe this is a gene that's involved
right maybe they get the polymorphism
there or something happens right so
so here you can click on each one of
these genes and see what
each of this is right so you can all
play around
with learning the different chromosomes
and uh what diseases cause each of these
chromosomes
and all of this this is just for fun you
can just take a walk i call this
this is the chromosome walk right so you
can take a long walk on the chromosome
and all of those things right so
now i am going to just um summarize
for you so maybe i can ask you what are
the what did you learn today
so you can put it in the chat what does
the main take home messages from today
right i don't want to overload you with
any more stuff because i think i talked
about a lot of different stuff right
so um what did you learn what was
what are the different things that you
learn each of you can just put some
things on the chat of what you actually
learned
what was your take home from today sasta
has
are you do you have a question yeah you
learned about snips
that's correct you got an idea about
bioinformatics that is fantastic yes you
got an idea
it was just like little bit of a flavor
for what informatics is right so
um you want to yeah so student genes
gerald is a very little difficult topic
we won't be covering that but then you
know what if i find some good articles
about it i'll
i'll send it your way i will i'll make
sure that it reaches you
yes introduction to bioinformatics you
learned about hatmap project
yes toby and so what is bioinformatics
now
after all this we have learned for two
hours what is bioinformatics how would
you define by bioinformatics now
different omics yes and if i were to
give you an exam
i want the specific term that we use
that just a small person yes
so sigma yes absolutely dr saraswati
that was a very good point yes monogenic
fantastic yes intro
yes i don't know if i'm saying your name
right i'm sorry if i'm not but it's it's
an introduction and i also learned a new
term
um what was the other term i learned it
was
um inter interaction right yeah
interpretation or interaction
integration of omic that's right a study
about solution for human disease is
absolutely correct
integration correct i'm going to write
it down um integration is right i think
i should go back in the chat and come up
with the other term that
you guys came up with that was amazing
interpretation okay
i will write it down interpretation
interpretation and
interaction i think it was interaction i
think that also filled in that spot
right
yes integra interaction that's correct a
few more good
um yes it is bridging rashmi beautiful
bridging genomics all of this fantastic
genotype to phenotype oh my goodness you
guys got the whole
gist of what i talked about today
amazing yes central dharma good sahasra
yes
satsakumar i'm sorry i'm just cutting
your name in short i'm sorry about that
um central dogma yes absolutely correct
um any other questions yeah you all got
the messages you got about human genome
project you got about
how many genes do we have did you get
about that uh insight into bind genomics
integration absolutely correct
23 pairs that's right so i guess 21 000
correct correct now you all know that we
have
anywhere between 20 20 500 to 22
000 genes right but how many protein
products do we have that's actually you
know what i said hundred thousand but
maybe it's a lot
more than hundred thousand right some
people think we have a million right i
don't know the right number
you just keep adding zeros to the
hundred thousand right
yes you're all correct so we learned
about the human genome project we
learned about the hapmap project
we learned about the encode project
which is just you know rest of the
genome
that contains the regulatory elements so
everything is
important in a genome that's another
take home right and bioinformatics is an
important field
i am just telling you one dot in osh in
the ocean
right so um that is pretty much the
summary of all of this this is fantastic
amazing i think you guys have amazingly
summarized everything i
i and you got it right so so now tell me
any questions that you have in the last
five minutes or so that we have
um um
but what is the importance of buy two
okay so is it thrown in one health
concept
so that's actually a very good question
right so
informatics is for any organism right so
when a dog gets sick you can sequence a
dog's genome to figure out
what gene is there in the dog that is
affecting it for most part it's a mammal
too right so
so that is pretty much what it is right
so why for my
omics don't get me wrong omics is for
any organism
right even microbial genomics we have
right
so pretty much anything you can compare
it and a
fantastic right so it is you can use the
data for any organism understanding
understanding a mouse understanding a
dog understanding a cat or
understanding any of those things so it
is uh
pretty much the same concepts are being
used for any organisms and all of this
data
either whether it's a rat or a mouse or
a cat
or a dog or anything all of this data is
actually at ncbi in all of these
resources
so if you're all back then we could
actually pull up those things
when we are doing the hands-on section
right yes
so um can we treat monogenic
monogenic diseases yes um anushka that's
actually a very very good question you
know
that now there is what is called
prenatal screening
so there are many genes that are
screened as you you're pregnant
to figure out whether something is going
to go whether you're going to carry
something that's good that you're going
to give birth to something with a
disease yes that is true but
can we correct them well you know what
the crispr cas9 technology is promising
but there are lots of ethical issues
around it so
right now i would say it is possible
from a practical aspect but in reality
is we still have a long way to go
because we have to you know we have to
jump a lot of humps to
get to all of those things right so
uh yes plants oh my god there's so much
of data on plants right so
um and yes and did i can we learn
machine deep learning to unlock yes of
course
so you know what um i must add here that
find
biotech and every single course that
uh you know you see on the platform
that's been created
in pine biotech right it's amazing it's
my favorite platform to use
you practically have all of this in bits
and pieces
put together in an amazing form to learn
and i think machine learning is actually
one aspect of them yes
we are at an era because we need a lot
of data right now before we can apply
machine to learn from us so that a
machine
can be useful um so machine learning is
actually very very important
right that is a buzzword right now and i
think um
ilia has an amazing uh course on that
actually in fact i get my students to
take
uh some of these courses as well myself
right so
so how is programming knowledge
important to buy information what level
of proficiency
so you know what my advice is
programming is if you're able to learn
programming
and the biology no one can beat you
you will be you know you will be called
and you will have so many options to go
to people will grab you
if you know programming and biology
together because it's an
asset to have so if you all are
interested in programming
it's an asset to have because you can
simply write scripts to mine this data
very quickly so i would urge
all of you have that bent of mind to
actually learn programming some level of
programming is sufficient
you don't need to be a pa so you need a
hardcore programming if you want to
develop a tool or
you know you know all of that but if you
just want to
get away with mining data then you know
um
you don't need to have an in-depth
knowledge about complicated programming
and uh yes anything
else any other am i missing anything i'm
not um
so let's see if i'm ah
fast befalls in this one r yes uh
could you please
okay so um
okay so some of you i i will need little
bit more time to respond to you
uh but i'm keeping a note of your
question and i will
i'll convey through saralika i will
convey the answers to you because
you know um some some projects in our
and some projects using
fastq files is amazing there are lots of
projects that you can practice with and
one project that comes to mind is you
can go to
a database called sra sra is a database
that has lots of sequencing data
so if you are uh if you're able to
download
um any disease that you're interested in
say like crohn's disease or type 2
diabetes
you can download the fastq files and
then use that
to go through the whole pipeline in our
uh for all of that so you can actually
pretty much go to sra database
and use all your skill sets um if that
has
answered your question so harsh i'm not
sure um yes there are lots of databases
where you can actually go and download
okay let's see um so i
i know that mohit or ilia if these on
the call can give you a little bit more
but i would say python
is an amazing language and r are the two
that i
feel that is very crucial and
important for bioinformatics because
most of the packages are in python
and r now everything is transitioning to
r so r
and python are are actually amazing
courses
to learn and i think i believe in um by
buy tech already has courses on those
right so
um so i think those two may be
um actually very very important um
in my opinion but of course ilya is um
and mohit can actually add to that and i
know that there are courses
in fact my students take courses yes
thanks
so just wanted to clarify to those of
you that are here on the call
we have a couple of things that
if you are interested in starting
machine learning
python coding r coding specifically for
bioinformatics for biomedical data
we have a number of these available
right here
so if you go to the courses tab you can
search here for r for example
and you can have a getting started with
bioinformatics just loading dna
sequences
analyzing multiple sequence alignment
visualizing that kind of data
or going for more advanced introduction
to data science
where you get to learn how to manipulate
different larger data sets how to
visualize them in various complex and
statistical
statistically meaningful way and then
also to
train your model and kind of understand
what that means so the same thing for
python
uh you have getting started with
bioinformatics and python
an introduction to data science and
python and many of these scripts are
going to be useful
if you just practice them understand how
they work and even save them
so later on as you continue working on
your project
you're doing some research these are
going to be very useful scripts you
might not necessarily become a
programmer
but in any case using these uh regularly
and having them stored and working on
your computer is going to be very useful
so you can explore those and then
obviously you can search through some of
the other coursework that is here some
of this
includes applications of these methods
to different types of project
examples
okay so thanks ilya um
if um i will if i think we are
um out of time so i'll i'll get sonalika
to conclude i guess sonalika and um
thank you all for your attention it was
wonderful to interact with you you
were all amazing and you gave me a lot
of energy to move forward
and thank you all i hope you learned
something from today's lecture
um hopefully you can develop yes um
thank you all
so much for your patience i know two
hours was a lot but hopefully
thank you so much dr sona thank you so
much
though i have done my bachelor's and
master's in bioinformatics but today in
your class even i was
like listening to each and everything
you told and it was
so amazing to listen to your talk
though i knew it all but i was just
wondering that
this is actually such a great way to
tell about all the concepts
and the way you told today i think none
of them
would ever forget like the basic
definitions the basic things
the those students were asking and so
you guys see this is just
a glimpse of what you saw sorry sorry
i'm so sorry for this
so this is just a glimpse of what you
will have in the whole program this is
the beginning it was a session one
and dr sona even i am very much excited
to hear to all your shocks now
so uh okay people are saying thank you
so much
thanks don and yes uh i would
be remembering you for my life as one of
the best teachers
sing just one session of yours thank you
just
one second thank you so much everyone
for your kind comments and
i love teaching um and and and i
i that's what i do for a living i love
teaching and i love
students especially you guys who are
very amazingly interactive so if you are
not interactive
then i wouldn't have gotten the energy
you know so i'm thank you thank you so
much and i'm glad you liked it thank you
yes exactly so thanks to you all
too because you all were really
interacting
asking questions and uh answering as
well
so it was great instead of having a very
quiet class with you all we had a really
interactive session and we would be
expecting the same in the other sessions
as well
so now let me just quickly take you
through the schedule
so i am first of all sharing the link
with you
so that you have it handy
okay here is the link we have all these
session details on this genomics in the
virtual lab blog here
we have the details of what all would be
covered in the program so the program
would be
two weeks of the program and unlike
other programs of
us the program would be continuous it
won't be on all alternative dates we
would be updating you on the
data as well so we have all the schedule
for the
uh program in the blog you can go
through it
and yes by the end of the program you
would definitely get to do a project
with dr
sona and yes as dr sona already told we
have
a guest speaker dr arigi from uh
we would be having a lecture on friday
so it would be really great to have you
all there
as well and here are the session
details with dates and what all would be
covered in each of these session
and i am once again sharing the link
of the registration page with you all so
that you have no
issue in registering yourself though
i've explained you all how you have to
do so
but let me just share the link quickly
and if you have any doubts
you can mail me at marketing at the
refine dot
bio we have doctor mohit with us you can
mail him also
at mohit at the rate pine dot fire and
he would be
very happy to help you
uh thank you is asking any feedback form
uh
i would definitely share a feedback form
over a mail but we don't have it right
now
so thank you everyone for joining elia
would you like to add something
no thank you i think this was a great
session again thank you dr sona for
joining us today and for everyone
joining as well
yeah thank you dr sona yeah thank you so
much
yeah thank you so much and uh good good
night
uh good morning and uh good evening and
uh
from all time zones thank you so much it
was fun as well thank you
see you thank you ma'am and thank you so
much everyone so let's meet tomorrow
then
and we'll have our second session
tomorrow so those who are
interested to register themselves uh you
would have to proceed with it
uh now itself or like within uh 10 to 15
hours so that i'm
able to share with you all the details
of the program
uh that's it and if you any doubts
please let me know do
i have shared my mail ids you can mail
me anytime
thank you so much yeah
bye bye everyone bye dr sona
yeah bye